this is a crazy story out of Australia
um we have we have quite a quite a few
viewers in Australia in fact it's one of
our outside of the U.S I mean it makes
sense it's a lot of English-speaking
countries Canada the UK and Australia
are where we have some of the biggest
audiences and uh close to 10 people sent
me this story about Australian
anti-vaxxers
completely fabricating the death of a
boy from Sydney Australia supposedly
from the covet vaccine it turns out it
was completely made up this is being
reported by seven news in Australia as
well as a number of other media Outlets
a distraught Sydney father has shared
how his beautiful seven-year-old boy
died in the back of an ambulance days
after being vaccinated against covid but
authorities say it's a hoax
in a lengthy Facebook comment Steve
Leary claimed his son Lachlan received
his first vaccine dose on Wednesday is
that a popular Australian name because
it isn't one of Rupert Murdoch's kids
also named Lachlan
um Lachlan received his first dose on
January 12th experienced a fever and
difficulty difficulty breathing shortly
after he claims he took his son to West
Med hospital where they ran tests and
after five hours sent him home Friday
morning at 4am we heard him yell out he
was on his bedroom floor he then
collapsed he was not breathing wrote the
father he claims his son died of a
massive heart attack and warns other
parents not to vaccinate the government
has ruined my family they have taken
away our only son I mean this this is
tragic if true
the post quickly gathered Pace online
collecting thousands of likes comments
and shares before the profile was taken
down and the post re-shared as a
screenshot
but it's believed to be the latest case
of misinformation running Rife a
deliberate attempt to discourage parents
booking in to get their children
vaccinated less than a week after 5 to
11 year olds became eligible for coveted
vaccines in Australia there is no record
of a Lachlan Leary who died in Sydney
last week or indeed at all
uh and nsw health told seven news it
quote has not been able to locate any
record of such incident and the
therapeutic Goods Administration which
collates all Adverse Events associated
with vaccines also rubbished the claim
in a statement statement a spokesperson
stressed it has not received any adverse
event reports involving the death of any
children between 5 and 11. the
Children's Hospital at Westmead also
refuted the reports in writing saying
there are many inaccurate posts
currently circulating on social media
there is no record of any child having
passed away following coveted
vaccination at our Hospital there are
also questions surrounding the validity
of Mr Leary's profile
news of the death pictured Leary a man
who lives in the United States and
served as the mayor of Winter Park a
small town in Florida
um this is uh this is this is really
immoral
um and everything we believe now
indicates that this is merely a hoax
meant to dissuade parents
from going and getting their kids
vaccinated against covet we are
fortunately seeing the decline of
Omicron now in the United States cases
down about 21 as of this morning we are
seeing uh a leveling out globally many
individual states in the U.S are down
significantly but
one of the groups that is most getting
seriously ill uh on a rate basis is the
very young
most of whom have not yet been
vaccinated and this is again it's
another opportunity to move to the
endemic phase it endemic doesn't mean no
risk but it means something different
than pandemic we have an opportunity
part of it is getting as many people
protected from getting seriously ill you
might catch it but you're much less
likely to be seriously ill 5 to 11 year
olds are part of that and this appears
to be an out and out complete and total
hoax and I hope that at least as far as
the US is concerned this reminds people
when you hear about veyer's reports
where tens of thousands of reports about
kids dead from the vaccine those reports
are completely unverified
anybody can go and submit a report to
theirs now people will write in they'll
say David it's it's a crime to do that
uh is anybody getting prosecuted for
that have you heard of anybody being
prosecuted for submitting a false report
to vayers that is not dissuading people
from doing it they are weaponizing the
vares report which is the vaccine
adverse effects Reporting System I
assume the s's system so an incredibly
pernicious moment and I am not
advocating one way or the other
Australia has different laws than the
United States it remains to be seen
whether this individual uh May face a
some kind of uh penalty of course if he
really lives in the United States it's
not really clear that anything would
apply but we're going to follow the
story that's everything we know right
now and we will have a link to the story
and more information on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman's
show
I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is Helix sleep I sleep on
a helix mattress at home I absolutely
love it and that's why I reached out to
them about sponsoring the David packman
show buying a mattress in the past was
always a huge guessing game for me I
didn't know what I actually needed I
didn't know what I would like but Helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress Helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired Magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every Helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but I know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video